begin with a first look at two men
accused in a road rage shooting now this
is 23 year old Donovan Stern and his
uncle 39 year old Zachary Stern North
Las Vegas Police say the shooting
happened yesterday just before 11 in the
morning officers say Donovan shot a
father and his six-year-old daughter
near Lone Mountain and 5th Street police
say Donovan left the scene after the
shooting he faces four counts of
attempted murder with a deadly weapon
detectives say his uncle Zachary
attempted to destroy evidence he was
also arrested on related charges both
victims were taken to the hospital with
gunshot wounds and they are expected to
be okay